THE ASCENT OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE NOTICING THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM THE COMMITTEE WILL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
MISERABLE OKAY ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
A LAW. REQUIRING THAT DRIVERS
FOR TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES UNDERGO BACKGROUND
CHECKS IN ESTABLISHING A LIST
OF CRIMES FOR WHICH DRIVERS
WOULD BE ON QUALIFIED. THIS
BILL AS IT LEFT THIS CHAMBER
WAS ORIGINALLY DESIGNED AS A
CODE CLEAN UP BILL TO THAT
LEGISLATION HOWEVER IN THE
SENATE WAS POINTED OUT THAT ONE
CRIME WAS INADVERTENTLY LEFT
OFF OF THE LIST OF
DISQUALIFYING CRIMES AND THAT
IS THE CRIME. A FELONY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THAT HAS A DIRECT
NEXUS TO CONSUMER SAFETY WHEN
WRITING IN THESE TRANSFERRED
TRANSPORT NETWORK COMPANY
VEHICLES. I WAS ASKED TO ADD
THAT TO THE LIST OF
DISQUALIFYING CRIMES IT SEEMED
REASONABLE TO ME SO THAT IS
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE THAT'S WHY
IT'S BEEN REFERRED BACK THIS TO
THIS COMMITTEE BUT WITHOUT THE
REQUEST WHITE RIVER
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. MR
OBERNOLTE WILL PICK THIS UP
WHEN YOU COMMITTEE. IS THERE
ANY SUPPORT. ANY OPPOSITION.
HEARING AND SEEING ONE MY
COMMENTS STILL SENATE WILL TAKE
IT UP ONCE WE CAN. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE BABIES. YOU HAVE
MANY MORE SPORTS MAYBE YEAH.
YEAH
. YEAH. YEAH OKAY.
EVERYBODY AT
. EVERY REPUBLICAN
THE PLACE NOW. CHECK THAT THEY
ARE IN THE BOOK. AND NOTICING A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SANTIAGO
OBERNOLTE BUT A WHOLE THAT
BONTA. BRO. CERVANTES EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE LOW
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
RODRIGUEZ. I THANK YOU MEMBERS
WE'VE NOW HEARD IN IN A SUB
COMMITTEE AB EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
WE WERE ABLE IT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE NOW WE HAE A QUORUM
HAVE A- MOTION A SECOND. REFER
RECOMMEND SECTOR PLEASE CALL
ROLE. MOTION WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I BURNED A
HOLE THAT BONTA BONTA AYE BRO
BRO I CERVANTES EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I CAN LOOK IT UP
COME ON A DOUBLE AYE LOW
PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SIGN. THANK YOU
NINETY SERVICES OUT. NINE ZERO
MEASURES OUT. LEVEL
. MAYBE
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK UP
NOT TO KERRY. AB EIGHT EIGHTY
HELLO LOW I TEND TO SERRA. YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT THE WHOLE. YEAH I.
OKAY BUT. YEAH ONE SECOND
LONGER YEAH. YEAH. YEAH THANK
YOU. FIGURES ABOUT THAT PART OF.
OKAY THANK YOU. MORE THAN
. THEY
WERE WONDERING ABOUT THE WAY IT
WAS. MISTER GARCIA OKAY IS MORE
THAN ENOUGH. WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT. IF THEY'RE ONE OF THE-
YEAH. OKAY OKAY
. JOHN. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH. OKAY. YEAH I WAS
AROUND. OF THE YEAH BEFORE THAT.
THE ABILITY OF THE WHOLE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB EIGHT
EIGHTY BURN A HOLE THAT. BUT A
WHOLE Và I MEASURES BEEN
DISPENSED WITH THE FINAL VOTE
IS ELEVEN TO ZERO. PROVISIONS
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE ABLE TO
CHORUS ADJOURNED